Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Invincible
Season 2 Episode 3 Video
There were a whole bunch Easter Eggs, wtf moments
A bunch of big characters
coming back into the story too
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
a lot of you probably recognize the voice.
It is Peter Cullen from Transformers
and like a billion other things doing the Voice.
All I could think was Optimus Prime
just leading the coalition here
Big reminder
that next week,
Episode four is like the midseason finale.
They'll go on like a short break
and then the other four episodes,
like the rest of the four episodes, are part
two of the season.
Whatever they call
it will be early next year. Some time.
they have not revealed when that's going to be
they'll probably release some season two part
two trailer that will have that information
sometime after episode four airs.
whatever winds up happening, of course I'll do videos.
Robert Kirkman
also said that they already pretty much finished season
three and we're finishing special effects
like the actual animation job on it.
So the whole goal from here on out
is to do one season per year, But
hopefully in season three there won't be like a break
in the middle of the season.
They'll just do all eight episodes, cable for spoilers
from episode three.
If you haven't seen it yet, we'll just start
at the beginning, work our way through shop.
Shall I talk about Easter eggs?
WTF moments?
Obviously the big reveal at the end of the episode
that you know, spoiler alert
omni-man is back in the story,
but that is right out of the comics.
Don't worry, we'll get to that.
There's so much to talk about, starting with the title,
this missive, this machination,
which is a reference to like the fake in-universe
universe, the alien episode they did it got super meta
with the titles and the way they broke the episodes
down into two different types of episodes this week.
like they did a fake in Universe
Island, the Alien episode.
Just to show you what's going on with him,
the Coalition of Planets said the Thetas character.
That's also a big deal to there's like a lot of lore,
like a lot of info dumps
that they did during this episode to explain characters
backstories in some of the backstory.
The coalition of planets,
not everything, but like a little bit
The missive part is also a reference
to Allen the aliens mission
that he was on that he's coming back
to tell them about what happened with Invincible.
but also it's a reference to the thorax.
And at the end of the episode
where he brings this missive to Invincible,
like you have to come to our planet.
THORAX There are billions of people's lives
that are threatened when really it's just a ruse.
in Omni-Man is using him for a secret plot.
Like it's not a sinister plot,
but it is a plot that I'll explain.
We get to that part of the episode.
They won't really reveal the truth
about why Omni-Man summoned
his son under false pretenses until episode four.
But his secret reason for doing
that is where they get into the machinations
part of the title of the episode.
also the idea that there's a mole inside
the coalition of plants informing the Viltrumites
what they're doing that part of the episode
is not from the comics like this whole subplot
within the coalition of planets
that the coalition is a big part of the comics,
but it's a much smaller part of the comics
than they're making on the TV show.
I explain this during my episode one video
a couple of weeks ago,
but the idea is that because they're hourlong episodes
and they want to do like seven or eight seasons,
in order to fill all that time,
they're adding a bunch of side stories for characters
they didn't necessarily get big stories in the comics,
for instance, his mother's storyline
with the whole Survivor support group of superhero
spouses like that was not part of the comics
all the stuff with Amber, a lot of the college stuff
that was not part of the comics
but they started the opening scene with his mother
dropping him off for his first week in college.
They do make a joke about this
at the end of the episode, too.
Like you're asking me to go off planet
and I haven't even started my first class yet,
the whole metaphor about pushing baby birds
out of nests,
him being able to fly also reminded me of the boys
TV show where Homelander tried
to teach Ryan how to fly
and wound up pushing him literally off the roof.
that was some quality eighties dad parenting
right there.
both of them addressed that.
They're still in the middle of grieving for
what happened with Omni-Man trying to deal with that
to set the big W to reveal at the end of the episode,
like, wait a minute, Dad, you're back.
and also all the drama
that Debbie goes through in this episode.
mostly though, is for that big WTF reaction
at the end of the episode, just to make it hit
a little bit harder.
Like they keep reminding you about Omni-Man Specter.
Like he's still alive. He's out there somewhere.
He didn't die.
He just took off Because literally we see where
that other place he went is at the end of the episode.
his mother also reminds him as he's starting college
and trying to figure out who he is
outside of being invincible.
There are a couple of jokes about this
at the end of the episode too,
where he tells the tractor, I'm like,
No, no, no, I'm in my costume.
You have to use my secret codename Invincible.
You can't call me Mark Grayson.
only man's real name is Nolan.
That's
what most of the other village roommates know him as.
only man is the fake name that he created for himself
when he created the superhero persona,
when he first came to Earth this whole idea of identity
will also get into Omni man's real backstory.
They kind of teased that during season one,
like he told a little bit of his backstory,
but we actually get into that in future seasons.
even though the title of the show is Invincible,
obviously Invincible is the main character.
A big part of the show is the redemption of Omni-Man
and we're going to start seeing that by episode
four in a while.
They're sort of developing that backstory,
like he's sort of processing his own history
as a vulture might like.
Remember, Omni-Man is very, very old.
you start to get more of the details
of his actual backstory.
There's a lot of secrets that they get into,
like things about Omni-Man backstory
that he himself does not know yet.
it's all in the comics, but it is kind of spoilery,
so we won't get too deep into that during this video,
but we will talk about it in future episodes
when they do start covering that stuff.
a lot of that gets into the whole Thetas storyline too.
There is a lot, a lot of stuff going on there
that they just barely tease in this episode.
seriously it is like tip of the iceberg
with some of these characters in these places.
They just introduced.
when they joke about not doing drugs, Mark is correct
in thinking that they wouldn't really work on him
because of his superhero physiology
is built to my physiology
unless he did every drug on the face of the planet.
end. Even then, we're only slowing down
for a little while until he healed that damage.
the only known compound that's actually
lethal to vulture mites is the scourge virus.
They don't really get into that
too much. During this episode.
There are a couple teasers like a couple characters
reference scourge, quote unquote, just to set that up
So we will talk more about the actual scourge
virus in future episodes.
It sounds like they'll get into that
a little bit more in the future.
The season Debbie calls the number on the help card
that Olga gave for the person.
She's speaking with his name, Carol,
The leader of the superheroes support group.
She's played by Leah Thompson. In real life.
They're like a lot of celebrity
guest stars during this episode, but generally
there's a lot of celebrity guest stars
in all the invincible episodes.
Robert Kirkman just must have a ton of famous friends.
They're just willing to come do the show for him.
the seance dog poster you might have detected is a Doctor
Strange Marvel parody inside the Invincible Universe.
It is a character from the comics,
he actually used to be called Science Dog,
but for whatever reason,
there was like some other character out there
that had the copyright to the science dog name.
So Robert Kirkman had to change the name to seance dog
looking around the room,
you noticed William's got posters of the Magnum P.I.
TV show, which seems like a weird
cat poster to have in your college bedroom.
Lady Yaya is obviously a Lady Gaga parody.
dee Dee should be a very obvious reference.
I shouldn't have to explain that.
Lobos is probably a lil Nas reference.
the w above his bed felt a little bit weird though.
Like that's a little bit on the nose.
they do all the jokes
about the trope of the sock on the door?
That's an old trope of college
movies, dudes getting it on, keeping the roommates out
without literally having to write it on the sign.
Like, Please stay out. I'm getting it on.
I feel like everybody has either
experienced this in real life
or like a version of it or seen it in the movie.
this bit has been around forever.
but there was some writer for this episode
having a little bit of fun
because Williams joke about eating tacos
could be taken in a number of different ways
like go out and eat someone else's
taco for a little while
or just eat a regular taco at a restaurant.
And speaking of which, there was a lot of taco
eating going on in this episode.
they even had Paul F Tompkins,
who was like the voice of the narrator in the episode
Super Meta, also joking about it like,
they're getting it on too.
Okay, well, why don't we just talk about this
alien cat for a little while?
everybody in
the invincible universe is super horny on Main
they make a bunch of jokes about Mark
being an adult toy collector.
There are literally hundreds of YouTube channels
dedicated
to adult toy collecting, so no shame there.
I myself still quote unquote collect stuff
every once in a while.
Notice this box of toys has since dog because they use
that later in the episode for a couple of twists.
The eye might be a reference to Marvel's XI McGrath.
The robot seems like a RoboCop reference.
The Green Soldier seems like a G.I. Joe.
Not sure about the yellow robot.
Maybe like a Transformers reference.
love that he gets super self-conscious tries
to dump them all but not sounds dog like.
Can't throw away his sounds dog.
sorry buddy, probably decided to twist later
in the episode where he's speaking to the thorax
and who's pretending to be sounds dog.
they pay off the joke with the sock on the door
to set up him getting it on with Amber,
also reminding you that they made fun of him
in previous episode for being a virgin still.
So Mark is basically losing his V card in this episode.
Everybody give him a round of applause.
probably the most notable thing here
with all these jokes about them getting it on
is that Mark very clearly has zero game
despite basically
being the most powerful person on the planet like he's
fiddling with his little sounds dog toy
when she's like okay let's get it on right now
they make a bunch of jokes about the physics
of superheroes having sex like Viltrumites getting it
on. part of this is meant to float the whole storyline
of the ultra mites interbreeding with other races
in Omni-Man as new family on anthrax, a
but in reality, because of their superior biology,
essentially Viltrumites are compatible
with most humanoid races in the galaxy,
like they can crossbreed
with pretty much any humanoid race
he turns off the lights at superspeed
and like his arm didn't grow.
Like he literally just crawled out from under her
at super speed turn the light up,
then crawl back under her so quickly
that she didn't even notice
That's also to remind you
how fast he is, even at his power levels.
And remember, he's
not nearly as powerful as Omni-Man yet.
so is only going to get faster,
only going to get stronger.
like I said, the narrator is Paul Tompkins.
He's not a character from the comics.
Luke is just some weird meta bit
that they did for the episode,
But I do like the idea that there's like some secret
super powerful being in a higher dimension,
watching this all play out, just commenting on it
like he's watching a TV show
any basically serves to tie up the origin story of Allen
the alien and the coalition of Planets with the title
of the episode flashing on screen, He basically does
a speed run version of Allen's back story.
It's right out of the comics.
he was originally from a planet called
you know before the scourge virus was created
when Viltrumites are still attacking planets in mass
like a big army of them would go plant the planet
and conquer that way they laid waste to their planet.
But some of them eventually wound up escaping.
They created a colony where they tried
to create super soldiers.
In Allen the Alien was the only successful attempt
they're couple special powers
that they teased during the episode that Allen has that
he didn't know that he has.
I'll get to that in a second.
We get to that part it's meant to play into the whole
subplot about there being a lot of sus characters
with secret plots in play during the flashback
where the Viltrumites are attacking Europa,
I think this one with the mustache
is meant to be like a young version of Omni-Man.
remember, they live for a very, very long time.
So this happened to their planet
a long, long time ago, the powerful galactic attention
that the narrator references is
the coalition of planets is basically the invincible
universe version
of the Federation of Planets from Star Trek.
that is in ducts that opens to the coalition,
brings them to the capital of terrestrial.
And they also use this to set up the rest
of the episode in present day with Allen coming back.
basically the coalition is just a group of planets
that band together
that hate Viltrumites
and want to stop them, led by Thetas, when Theta calls
the Viltrumites a scourge to the universe,
that's also a reference to the scourge virus,
Maybe they'll start teasing that in either next week's
episode of like the second half of the season.
It's still pretty early
because there's a bunch of Viltrumites related story
that we probably won't get into like season three.
they get into more of Allen's backstory,
saying that they tested him
by setting him directly against Viltrumites,
but it was unsuccessful.
Like he got his ass pounded to him.
So they set him on a mission to just go around
the rest of the universe looking for other people
that were super powerful
and could help them fight Viltrumites
that's how he ultimately wound up meeting Invincible,
they make a couple jokes in the episode
about how he made the dumb joke, the spelling error
that put him at Earth instead of, Ooh, wrath.
and they give the narrator pull out of Tompkins
the invincible title trope
in this episode where he almost says the title,
but then it flashes on screen.
But they also do the meta thing
of turning it into the Allen the Alien title,
the actual blood that flashes on
the screen is meant to be Allen's blood, Mostly
to reference the end of his part of the episode
where the village mites also beat the crap out of him
again, he wasn't traveling back to the last area
the Capitol building in.
The idea is this scene is meant to be taking place
in the past right after the end of season one.
right after he got done talking to Invincible,
he flew right back to the coalition of planets.
So this is taking place maybe like a couple of months
in the past He's met by General Telia,
who's also voiced by Tatiana maslany, who also voiced
the queen of the Atlanteans in last week's episode.
Telia is Allan's girlfriend from the comics.
She's another powerful member of the coalition.
the whole side plot
where she talks about the action plan being hit
by the Viltrumites
in this secret informer inside the council.
That's all Bran knew that was not part of the comics
Like I said, that's part
of the idea where they're trying to expand storylines,
like give characters
more story that they didn't get in the comics
because they're trying to fill more time.
but basically the idea is the Viltrumites
are going after all the worlds right
after they join the coalition of planets
also turning off
other potential members that want to join
or would have joined otherwise.
basically cutting off the coalition from more support,
keeping it hampered
so that they never grow powerful enough to challenge
the build from ice.
When Allen addresses
the council, notice that there's a member a battle
being raised on the council
because they're so powerful.
battle bees is meant to be kind of
like a parody of Mongul from DC Comics
Then it reveals everything that happened with Omni-Man
in Invincible two Thetas
There is a bunch a bunch of future storyline in secrets
with fetus's backstory.
I don't want to get too much into that
because it is kind of spoilery,
But let's just say that they
this was surprise in this episode about the existence
of the invincible character because of the way
the filter might have changed their tactics.
without explaining too much
about how he knew the old build to my tactics.
The idea is that Viltrumites in present day
under the leadership of Thrasher
basically changed their tactics
for conquering the universe to basically get around
the problem of the scourge virus
the whole idea is that their race used to go around
conquering planets the old fashioned way
with like a giant fleet, like they destroy a planet.
Take it over.
but then the scourge virus almost wiped out their
entire race, reducing their numbers to a fraction.
then they started their special plan,
like their stealth plan for conquering the universe
one planet at a time, by basically having their members
go out in interbreed with the locals.
They'd wait for their half breed son
or daughter to mature or get their powers
and then use them to take over that plan.
And that's how they would take over the universe.
The slow way round one planet at a time
So you think Thetas reacting in such a surprised way
at the knowledge that Invincible even exists like, wow,
why would they interbreed with somebody
is because they want to say
within the context of the TV show, Thrasher
just started this side, you know, stealth plan
for conquering the universe recently.
Like it's a brand new thing.
otherwise Thetas would have figured out
what the Viltrumites were doing a long time ago.
when he mentions Viltrumites
fighting other Viltrumites.
Not happening since the Great Purge.
That's what we saw in the flashbacks during season one,
when Omni-Man was revealing
the true history of their race
like they fought a brutal civil war
to cleanse all the weaknesses from their race,
leaving only the strongest to live.
So the fact that Thetas knows
about the history of the Viltrumites
in seemed keenly aware of the Great Purge.
Like he kind of strokes his beard
a little and looks sideways.
That should be a hint to you if you've not read
the comics, you can actually go read about.
They this is BackStory right now if you want.
But the whole idea is that now
Thetas believes that he has two
potential Viltrumites that can help them fight
the rest of the Viltrumites
in three
The whole idea that Omni-Man abandoned his mission,
which Viltrumites never do,
in the fact that the son, who is also a Viltrumite,
now turned against his father.
So like potentially to that do not follow
the military might ways.
than all the talk about the Viltrumites
believing in racial purity is part of the old ways
before the scourge virus
almost completely wiped them out Afterwards
they use the interbreeding program
to both conquer the universe the slow way.
But they also learned that the half breeds were less
susceptible to the scourge virus than the pure bloods.
so as a way to one replenish their numbers way faster,
but also to sort of sidestep the scourge virus.
this is also part of the reason
why Mark Invincible is capable
of becoming stronger than all the Viltrumites
because he is a half breed.
so the whole concept of introducing other racist
gene pools
into their own
theoretically making them even stronger, race
Omni-Man also kind of explained this like a hand
hand-waving kind of way during season one.
Like very briefly basically
saying that votes are my blood, essentially built for
my genes are so powerful
that they overpower the other genes in someone's body.
So most of Mark's blood is built for my blood.
they said that the whole subplot about the voter
might inform it on the council.
This wasn't a big part of the comics.
Like I said, I think they're
using this story on the show so that Allen the alien,
will find the informant and it'll be a big reveal like,
you're informing the vulture mites on us.
but also to say that the reveal about
who Thetas really is too
like he thinks he found them all but there's also an
even bigger secret in what's going on with Thetas.
they get super horny
like everybody on all the different planets everywhere.
Start getting it on all at the same time.
Probably the horniest episode of Invincible so far.
Don't worry, because they will probably get thornier
than this in future episodes.
Afterwards when they're eating at the diner.
I love the whole joke here too, about their gross food.
She thinks that his grub creatures are gross
just on their own, but she's eating the brains
of a creature out of its skull while it's still alive,
and also at the same time eating those same grubs
They're giving the telly a character
a way, more scenes that weren't in the original comic,
like they were just girlfriend boyfriend in the comics,
but I think they're expanding on this because, one,
they have Tatiana maslany. She's a pretty big actress.
but like I said,
they're trying to turn some of these side characters
into bigger stories just to fill up more episodes.
Allen gets jacked by three Viltrumites.
Remember,
he wasn't powerful enough to stop one of them.
So three of them,
He has absolutely no chance against Notice
they're familiar with him
so they don't even bother to move their lips.
They just think they're thoughts.
And he's telepathic, so we just picks them up
All three of these Viltrumites are from the comics.
Two of them eventually do,
y'know, tracking down Omni-Man Invincible anthrax.
That might be during the events of episode four,
You might also remember
this same female vulture might from the flashbacks
in season one.
Remember, they live for a very, very long time.
This one right next to her is Conquest.
He's also a huge character from the comics.
Maybe by season three I'm not expecting in season two.
notice
they know everything about Invincible and Omni-Man in.
Allen had not yet told his girlfriend Telia.
I think to let you know that his girlfriend was not
the informant is probably going to wind up
being either one of the other council members
or one of those two data
analysts that he gave the same information
to before he went to the council,
because they'd have access to all that same information
to They beat him within an inch of his life.
But he can't heal the damage, though. Don't worry.
We'll get to that in a second because there's a big WTF
cliffhanger that they leave His episode
on the real reason why Thetas seemingly deactivates
his healing chamber is a big misdirect.
They just want you to think that,
he says, when really it's part of
how Allen's powers work in the comics,
his body will heal the damage.
And it's kind of like a doomsday DC Comics parody.
any time doomsday gets killed or hurt really badly,
he'll heal the damage,
but it'll come back even stronger.
It's the same phenomenon with Allen the alien.
So once his body eventually heals the damage,
he'll be almost as powerful as the villager mice.
Whereas he wasn't even close before.
they this is basically turning off his stasis
chamber to jumpstart that process.
so he's not trying to hurt him
because he wants him dead.
He just wants him to heal even faster.
Knowing how his powers work.
then they slam to the credits in like a super meta way
to make you think like the episode is over.
Let me know how many of you that were watching
this actually thought that the full episode
was over here when the credits started playing like,
Wait a minute, it's only 30 minutes long.
Like what happened to the other 30 minutes?
they get super meta.
So like when they jump back to the normal part
of the episode
with the Guardians of the Globe, you actually start
hearing duplicates breath as she's lifting weights
as the credits are still playing so that you know that
the episode is still going there are probably a couple
of people out there though that turn the episode off
like, well, I guess that's in the episode.
Wait till next week.
They go back to the Guardians of the Globe
in present day.
Just remind you about duplicates.
Powers Look, the whole idea is that anything
that one of them does, the others also feel like
the main body feels anything the duplicates do,
including dying, which you reference is later.
So like only one of them here
needs to actually work out.
The others will get the benefit
they also show you her absorbing her duplicates
We haven't seen very often on the show
in basically remind you that she's essentially died
many, many hundreds of times because her duplicates
have been destroyed many times in battles.
So she's known what it's like to die many, many times,
like the immortal who's also literally died
many, many times.
And they just been brought back because of his powers
You also remember that she has a brother
who was in prison in episode one.
We'll probably see him come back
at some point during the season.
he basically has the exact same powers.
They got their powers
because of a curse that one of their ancestors got.
they said the monster girl in robot storyline,
where she jokes about why
Rex doesn't understand
the deep connection that duplicate Immortal have.
Like she has the same connection with Robot
because they both live in kind of curse body,
so to speak Like they've both been cursed
by their biology in different ways.
Like hers is because of an actual occurs
robot's body is basically
just him getting the poor luck of the draw
when he was born.
they also remind you
that monster girl has knocked the hell out of Rex.
That was back during season one
they're couple more jokes with Shane Smith
just being super weird not quite fitting in.
I think just to tease the fact that they'll learn about
where he really comes from,
who he really is, pretty soon,
they tease Monster Girl in robots relationship.
They go to the movies.
They have that whole joke
about how she basically has to pay someone else
to get them tickets because they're not old enough
to get into R-rated our movie.
that's more of a phenomenon In the United States.
Every country has sort of like a similar rating system
where like only adults
are allowed to see certain kinds of movies
or you have to have parental supervision.
she basically reminds Robot
that she's had to do this several times before
because of the way her curse words, like she's
looked like a little kid for a long time now.
She's learned the ropes of how to get around,
why she's looking like a little kid,
all the movies here are just parodies
of generic horror movies
like Midnight Slaughter, Ritual,
Feline Cobras, alloy COG
Senior Loop feels like a very specific meta joke
about old people being on loops.
all the posters are meant to be like generic horror
posters like The Wolfman and Dracula, for instance.
She also starts to realize
that robot hasn't really done
anything that normal kids did
Because his whole life, like his entire childhood,
was spent inside of Stacy's tube, literally
the sun would burn his skin.
Susie takes him to Burger Mart, like the same Burger
mart that everybody on the show goes.
it's a really big city.
But somehow they all wind up
at the exact same Burger Mart.
So maybe it's burgers are just that good.
They said that the whole superhero
support group for Debbie.
This is the spouses of superheroes.
Theo is played by Daveed Diggs.
we find out that he used to be the husband of Green
Ghost, who's a Green Lantern
parody from DC and was killed by Omni-Man
during the events of episode one.
kind of a downer ending for that storyline
because he basically runs her out of the group like,
you better not come back. It won't be safe for you.
Implying that he is going to do her some violence
if she comes back.
I think a lot of that ending for that storyline too,
where she's like, I wish he was dead, but he's not.
He's out there somewhere.
Is this a set up that big W TV reveal
at the end of the episode where we actually do see
where that other place he went is all the Debbie stuff,
like I said, is not from the original comics.
It's just part of her expanded storyline
this season We go back to college.
And they remind us about William's boyfriend,
who was turned into a Rihanna in last season.
Cecil saying,
That'll be fine. Soon might be a misdirect.
Like, we'll see, because those alterations to his body
seem pretty permanent.
Then we get the big thraxan's
reveal with the seance dog like it's basically a thraxan
pretending to be seance dog using his powers.
And he's voiced by Rob Delaney from Deadpool 2.
Peter from Deadpool 2.
Basically when he says the journey to earth from
Thorax has taken most of his life,
that's because they have ultra short lifespans,
not much longer than a week or two.
like almost his entire life
winds up being about six days.
some of the stuff he tells to Invincible is true
and some of it is obviously a boldfaced lie.
Like when he says the rest of the universe has started
hearing rumors about your existence.
That's not totally a lie.
Like people have started to learn about it,
but all the stuff about saving his race
from the meteor showers.
That's a huge lie.
He's there
secretly on omni man's orders to bring him back
so that he can start to atone for what he did
it also set up something that going to pay off
in episode
four with Omni-Man as New Family on this other planet.
merrily theory right now they'll pay this off
in episode four is that the Viltrumites
who were looking for on the man's whereabouts,
That's why they almost killed Allen the alien.
Omni-Man will realize the Viltrumites
are going to come for him
and he wants to save the life of his new son,
Invincible, his half brother.
So that's why he called.
And they're like, Please take your half brother
back to earth with you to protect him from the other
Viltrumites
Thus begins the redemption of Omni-Man
and probably a really big vote
for my battle during episode
four is sort of like a mid-season cliffhanger.
like I said,
Omni-Man is like a big, big part of the story for like
the rest of what the show is going to be.
when William references the last time
that he was reluctant to help save someone.
He's talking about in Invincible,
not saving his boyfriend until it was too late,
until after he'd been turned into a reanimated.
Then the clue that Braxton was lying to him
about who he was, what his mission was,
should be that he knows Mark Grayson is his full name.
He should know that They also tease more friction
between him and Cecil
because he defies his orders, leaving the planet
that will only continue to get worse.
remember, Cecil's been developing all these contingency
plans to fight Viltrumites behind the scenes.
even though Invincible is trying to be a good person,
good superhero, protect the planet, at some point
we will see him have to fight Cecil in some way
They have a couple of jokes about the six days
travel it's going to take to get to Thorax
and how he's going to survive all that boredom.
but then they arrive and reveal
the monarch is his father Omni-Man
We'll talk a bunch more about what happened on Drax,
like what Omni-Man did after he left Earth.
When we get to episode four. So went to wait that long.
but if there are any other Easter eggs or references
that you spot in the episode that I didn't talk about
in the video, just write them below in the comments
my full episode for video we'll post next week.
we also just got a what if season two trailer video
those episodes will be happening
at the end of December.
That'll be like the next big animated show that I do.
click here for that trailer and click here
for all my other Invincible videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!